we have a story about a pair of
educators in dallas
going above and beyond a recent united
way's report
found that over half the households in
dallas
have trouble affording basic needs so
this couple
launched a non-profit to help students
and they're here to tell us about it
please welcome jessie akan acosta and
alejandra zendejas
hi guys you were big fans of your work
thank you the next season of santa
clarita
jesse thank you you know i've been
thinking about where sheila hammond is
never i mean there's a few characters
i've been lucky enough to
be a part of that i feel like i got to
be very myself in and
surprisingly sheila is one of them um
but jessie you are a high school teacher
and alejandra you're a tutor and you're
a couple right
yes and you're both proclaimed
sneakerheads so for those who don't know
what a sneakerhead is can you explain
that yeah so a sneaker head is what we
are we love
shoes it is a big part of the culture
here in old cliff
um and that is specifically true in
urban schools like the one that i teach
at
yeah and the secret culture here is so
strong that people often look at
others feet before they even look at
your face
well and before the pandemic you notice
there was like a need
for sneakers with your students talk to
us about that right so
i mean as you as i mentioned here and
where i teach that we always
look at the sneaker as we look at feet
beforehand and one thing that i noticed
was that
students with beat up shoes or worn out
shoes were more likely to be
bullied or to even isolate themselves
from the rest of the crowd and i was
going to give him a pair of shoes but i
just wouldn't i don't
i didn't want to offend anybody and we
talked about it
and it wasn't until copenhagen where my
students were telling me like
my parents are losing jobs we lost
somebody in the family because of cobit
and so we that was the last drop for us
and we decided to just do it and give it
a try
it just became something really
important for us you started
paso's for oak cliff this summer to
raise money to buy your students brand
new sneakers
what has been the impact so far of that
the impact so far
right we additionally wanted to give 50
pair of shoes and we were able to
fundraise triple the amount of what we
intended
so we were able to give and fifty pair
of shoes which is still crazy for us
and from there i mean we got to see how
the kids were reacting as we gave them
away
a lot of them couldn't believe it they
thought that we were going to be like
psych
give a little shoes back would you guys
like to continue this
oh yes definitely there's no way we can
stop at this point
well we want to uh support in every way
that we can so
chris miller and i called our friend
jared margolis at payless shoes and
they're going to donate 500
pairs of shoes to your organization
today
and i thank you so much
and i'm also going to donate 5 000 to
your organization to keep this
going thank you
jesse and alejandra for everything that
you're doing
and we are so inspired by you so let's
stay in touch if we can
because i want to see you grow in this
journey really
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you for having
us and i mean we love you
today we have a story about a pair of
educators in dallas
going above and beyond a recent
united way's report found that over half
the households in dallas
have trouble affording basic needs so
this couple
launched a non-profit to help students
and they're here to tell us about it
please welcome jessie akan acosta and
alejandra zendejas
hi guys i see you were a big fan of your
work
thank you the next season of santa
clarita
jesse thank you you know i've been
thinking about where sheila hammond is
she might be around
never i mean there's a few characters
i've been lucky enough to
be a part of that i feel like i got to
be very myself in
and surprisingly sheila is one of them
um
but jessie you are a high school teacher
and alejandra you're a tutor and you're
a couple right
yes and you're both proclaimed sneaker
heads so for those who don't know what a
sneaker head is can you explain that
yeah so a sneaker head is what we are we
love shoes
it is a big part of the culture here in
old cliff
um and that is specifically true in
urban schools like the one that i teach
at
yeah and the secret culture here is so
strong that people often look at
others feet before they even look at
your face
well and before the pandemic you noticed
there was like a need
for sneakers with your students talk to
us about that
right so i mean as you as i mentioned
here and
and where i teach how we always look at
the sneakerheads we look at feet
beforehand
and one thing that i noticed was that
students with beat up shoes or worn out
shoes
were more likely to be bullied or to
even isolate themselves from the rest of
the crowd
and i was going to give him a pair of
shoes but i just wouldn't i don't want
anyone to offend anybody
and we talked about it and it wasn't
until kobe hit where my students were
telling me like
my parents are losing jobs we lost
somebody in the family because of kobe
and so we that was the last draw for us
and we decided to just do it and give it
a try
just became something really important
for us you started paso's
for oak cliff this summer to raise money
to buy your students brand new sneakers
what has been the impact so far of that
the impact so far
right we additionally wanted to give 50
pair of shoes and we were able to
fundraise triple the amount what we
intended
so we were able to give 150 pair of
shoes which is still crazy for us from
there i mean we got to see how the kids
were reacting as we gave them away
a lot of them couldn't believe it they
thought that we were going to be like
psych
give a little shoes back would you guys
like to continue this
oh yes definitely there's no way we can
stop at this
point well we want to uh support in
every way that we can
so chris miller and i called our friend
jared margolis at payless shoes and
they're going to donate 500 pairs of
shoes to your organization
today
and i thank you so much
and i'm also going to donate 5 000 to
your organization to keep this
going thank you
jesse and alejandra for everything that
you're doing
and we are so inspired by you so let's
stay in touch if we can
because i want to see you grow in this
journey really
[Music]
you